bueno creo que haya tomado suficientes
vacaciones
[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola a todos como están ya que estuve
ausente un largo largo tiempo creo que
fueron ya bueno no lo sé bastantes meses
más de los que me hubiera gustado pero
ya puedo irme de nuevo el tiempo y el
espacio para seguir con el vídeo y con
suerte sacar una sonrisa los que me
siguen y bueno sé que han pasado muchas
cosas desde que me fui como bueno
[Música]
pero ya habrá tiempo para eso por ahora
vamos a hablar de lo que nos gusta
videojuegos en especial un tema que pasa
desapercibido por la mayoría de personas
a la hora de jugar sí exacto nuevos
detalles porque vamos a que no le guste
disparando a todo lo que se mueva en el
viejo oeste y de repente darse cuenta
que los desarrolladores del juego
pusieron una atención casi enfermiza a
los huevos de los caballos que a nadie
bueno con un [ __ ] porque a rockstar le
encanta
y de eso vamos a hablar hoy de
desarrolladores con tanto cariño de sus
creaciones que no les importan gastar
mucho de su tiempo en pequeños detalles
que probablemente no muchos vean y sean
bastante inútiles en ocasiones pero que
nosotros aprendimos bastante que está en
el juego final
de verdad bastante genial que se tomen
el tiempo de saiz como estos
detalles como el cuerpo de kratos de
músculo su cuerpo para soltero
el último más reciente god of war es un
juegazo vamos a señalar que hemos de ir
del año pasado y bien merecido porque
aparte de ser un juego genial tiene
bastantes detalles como el mencionado
cuerpo carbó y albín retratos que
reacciona al ambiente es decir si te
tiras al lado te llenarás de lodo si
estás en un ambiente con nieve estás y
te deja el cuerpo incluso con el
carácter de kratos cuando le das una
golpiza a un enemigo su se atrinchera tu
piel y armadura
y para santo este insignificante y hasta
unidos pero es algo que no muchos juegos
tienen y un detalle que ciertamente
ayuda a la inmersión del juego
pasamos a pride and first person shooter
sorpresivo e innovador que hace tiempo
nos sorprendió a todos con sus mecánicas
en este juego te enfrentas a enemigos
con poderes psíquicos con un arsenal de
armas no convencionales además de tú
mismo tener habilidades de mimetizarse
con el ambiente así que en que éstas ya
se pueden ha fijado los desarrolladores
bueno te hace un baño sí pues
dependiendo del género de tu personaje
en una parte del juego encontrarás que
el asiento del baño está arriba o abajo
dependiendo de si eres mujer u hombre
con un chador terminado y down se lució
creando una de las mejores salas de
acción y aventuras hasta el momento en
su cuarta entrega está llena de pequeños
detalles que con un buen ojo podrías
notar un ejemplo de estos son los
elementos de los escenarios con los que
interactúas más específicamente bolsas
de arena con las que te puedes cubrir
cuando te lías a tiros con 50 soldados
armados estas bolsas actúan como
esponjas que absorben de una forma
realista los disparos evitando que vayan
a ir en tu culo aventurero
o incluso tienen una animación fluida
para cuando la arena comienza a salir
por los agujeros de bala
vamos a otro juego de disparos de
división en este juego podrás encontrar
unas muñecas matrioska no sé si lo ha
pronunciado bien bueno en este juego las
encuentras y en vez de ser unos simples
pisapapeles y les disparas verás que sus
muñecas verdaderas y tiene unas muñecas
adentro cada vez más pequeñas
[Música]
y
estamos ahora en el mar más
específicamente en si of tips un juego
con unos visuales hermosos unas
mecánicas interesantes el detalle es que
si te pasas de copas y terminas borracho
no necesariamente debes esperar que los
efectos de la borrachera recordar tu
cuerpo como en otros juegos resulta que
sea un compañero llena un balde con agua
y te lo arroja la borrachera habrá
desaparecido
[Música]
nos movemos ahora a egipto en assassin's
creed origins obviamente al estar
ambientado en el antiguo egipto tenemos
muchísimo territorio desértico para
explorar divertirnos con arena y más
arena con tanta calor ambiente tan
extremo si llegamos a nuestro personaje
que sea un paseo corriendo sobre la
arena durante mucho tiempo el cansancio
y la calor hará que comencemos a
alucinar
siguiendo con unas aguas ya bastante
gastada el call of duty más exactamente
el black ops un spoiler en una parte
atrás cuenta de que eres no un aliado
tuyo que te ayudó durante todo el juego
siempre estuvo muerto y todas las veces
que lo vemos en el juego son solo
alucinaciones de tu personaje pero antes
de que nos den esa revelación casi al
final del juego hay una manera de saber
la verdad mucho antes los que conocen ya
la saga call of duty sabrán que cuando
le disparas a un aliado te puede
penalizar o castigar por matar aliados
pero si le disparas al resto en
cualquier parte del juego no pasará nada
no te castigará ni básicamente nada
claramente porque héroes no es una
alucinación no un aliado es un detalle
bastante curioso
y bueno
i
[Música]
volvemos a uncharted 4 donde hay un
detalle bastante genial que si no pones
atención lo perderás de vista en el
capítulo 11 llegará un momento donde
pasarás por un edificio al que unas
personas le van a aplicar una nueva capa
de pintura hasta ahí todo correcto
bastante normal sola se parte un fondo
pero más adelante y después de unos
cuantos madrazos con tus enemigos
pasarás de nuevo por el mismo edificio y
verás que ya fue completamente pintado
es un detalle que aunque no sirve
absolutamente nada muestra la dedicación
de los desarrolladores para hacerte un
chal de 4 un mundo lleno de vida
[Música]
hacemos otro lugar donde no todo el que
nos vea quiere meternos una bala en el
cráneo
algo más amigable y colorido kirby estar
a la jce ya todos conocen a kirby esta
bonita rosa que absorbe una parte de los
poderes de lo que sea que entre a su
boca en fin si por accidente en vez de
comerte un enemigo te comen solos un
reloj tu enemigo se va a deprimir por ha
perdido
baic
se ve tierno pero esto un hijo de [ __ ]
spider-man de insomniac games para una
sorpresa en su momento porque bueno me
casi ningún juego superior es bueno por
mayoría son [ __ ] pero este juego
resultó ser genial y estar lleno de
detalles todos conocemos a spider-man y
en su código de honor de no matar pero a
pesar de eso convocamos a veces llegamos
a lanzar enemigos fuera de tejados desde
grandes alturas claro nosotros pensamos
que se murieron los malos pero no el
juego nos da una muestra de la moral de
spider-man al ver que los enemigos
lanzados en vez de caer son salvados por
las telarañas de spider-man
factor 5 es un nuevo controversial
algunos lograron otros la mano pero sea
cual sea tu opinión hay que estar de
acuerdo que tiene un bello mundo abierto
con una gran cantidad de detalles como
por ejemplo un perrito
si tu personaje saca a pasear a su perro
por ejemplo mientras corre él sacará su
lengua con un perro real además si lo
llevas a un lugar con agua el perro
comenzará a jugar y si previamente
jugaste con él o estuvo corriendo tomara
un trago de agua
[Música]
volvamos a sus escritos pero ya no a
egipto a grecia
y no no es grecia en assassin's creed or
y si este juego tiene unos mapas de
mundo abierto más grandes en los últimos
tiempos hace que detalles no le van a
faltar y éste es bastante bello ya que
si te encuentras navegando en tu arco y
si tienen la suficiente suerte te
encontrarás con que habrá delfines que
nadan a tu lado y acompañen a tu novio
en su viaje
y
de un bello mundo del pasado vamos a un
futuro post apocalíptico con de las
tropas en una parte del juego nos
encontraremos a un superviviente que nos
acompañará una parte del camino si
exploramos encontraremos una carta que
pertenece o bueno pertenecía a un
compañero suyo que murió al recogerla en
el inventario tiene un aspecto pulcro y
liso luego a entregársela el tipo de
cabaré a la arruga y la lanza y si
nosotros la recogemos y la leemos de
nuevo en el inventario ya no aparecerá
como nueva aparecerá arrugada como el
tipo la dejó al tirarla
[Música]
en mario de este encantador juego hay
bastantes detalles pequeños por ejemplo
si te quedas quieto lo suficiente mario
eventualmente se cansará de que no hagas
nada y esa hormiga pero si lo escuchas
una atención darse cuenta que habla
dormido y mientras toma su siesta entre
los niños comienza a decir nombres de
distintos tipos de pasta incluso llega a
decir un nombre y la princesa pecho
[Música]
estará soñando
[Aplausos]
[Música]
finalmente vamos a los que todos están
esperando porque estás buscando desde el
inicio del vídeo caballos ojos y desde
lanzamientos geniales web dead
redemption 2 cada momento se encuentran
más detalles en el juego una muestra del
cariño que restarle todo el juego
durante el desarrollo y uno de los
detalles más inútiles y bizarros pero
increíbles es que el equipo
desarrollador que yo increíblemente
necesario para físicas a los testículos
de los caballos
es decir si tu caballo está en el
ambiente cómodo puedes
[Música]
bien en el paño de esos huevos pero si
llevas a tu compañero a un ambiente frío
se encogerán lógicamente
sí
todos estos detalles aunque algunos algo
inútiles y que le afecta en lo más
mínimo el juego son demuestra el aprecio
que los desarrolladores le tienen a sus
propias creaciones y es algo increíble
que se tomen el tiempo en hacer esta
clase de cosas vamos que yo también me
tomaré mi tiempo para los sueños húmedos
amario con pitch
[Música]
si alguno de ustedes saben más detalles
como esto si quisieran la segunda parte
de este vídeo de gemelos a ver en los
comentarios
quiero tomar estos últimos segundos del
vídeo para agradecer a todos ustedes los
que se quedan mientras estuve ausente
apoyándome en serio muchas gracias ep al
menos hasta la próxima
ah
i
a
ah
[Música]